welcome to the all-new gridiron heights
sports book gambling gambling if you
gamble it's like you're playing two
we're kicking it off with a special wild
card tournament i finally get to play
i'm alive i swear use promo code golfer
bad
this is my first time in a casino really
derek is a curfew vegas non-vegas idiot
wow mvp caliber ray's there brady how
much sorry didn't quite catch that check
out though
you see kids jerry jones is like mr
krabs if he made his money from
aggressive oil refining a set of burgers
don't like a paralyzing sunflower at an
indoor facility play outside check but i
went all in check check check over under
how many times will stanford blow it can
everyone stop yelling at me i told you
fam we folded back in week 14.
the game's over
this team reminds me of the 2001
patriots they're no longer playing fun
fact no one has ever sent a text about a
borough playoff laws i keep adding next
week when green bay takes on the niner
well where's alex smith now
[Music]
you know how when your board of rugrats
is just waiting for the loud house to
come on that's like jimmy g and trey
lance a third down is like the smurfs i
will not elaborate see safety's like
rocking power what's that that's not on
anymore you're lost kids